a little-known truth behind an american
whiskey brand is helping shape an
effort to bring some diversity to the
industry in 2016 the legendary jack
daniels brand acknowledged
that it was an enslaved man named nathan
nearest green who taught a young jack
daniel how to make whiskey
after that a new whiskey brand called
uncle nearest was created in his honor
i visited last year and i recently went
back to see how it's become the fastest
growing independent american whiskey
brand
ever i remember this room
didn't look like this nothing at all in
the years since our last visit to
shelbyville tennessee
we can bottle a million bottles a year
in here
fawn weaver the co-founder and ceo of
uncle nearest whiskey
has transformed this horse farm into a
distillery honoring the first known
african-american master distiller has
that all sunken in yet
i don't think so the first time we got
together i said listen
i want to make sure that nearest green's
name is known around the world
while i'm still here i'm making up lost
ground
160 years of no one knowing this man's
name his name was known around lynchburg
where nearest green a former slave met
an orphan named jack daniel
and taught him how to make whiskey on
this farm
the only reason any of us know about
nearest green is because jack made sure
when he was alive
that everyone knew nearest was so
integral
to what he did weaver is honoring
green's legacy while making some history
of her own
as the first female and black ceo of a
major spirit brand
but she says that's not enough we can't
diversify our industry if we're not
getting any resumes
so she's teaming up with jack daniels to
create the nearest and jack advancement
initiative
a five million dollar project that aims
to increase diversity
and promote african-american leadership
in whiskey
black enslaved people were so skilled
at distilling well then we have
prohibition we come on the other side
we've got other options
generally speaking african-americans are
not going to choose to go
into industries in which our ancestors
did not have a choice in the matter
so you will not see us in tobacco you
will not see us in cotton
you will not see us in american whiskey
usually trying to change that
they're hoping an apprenticeship program
and distilling school
will bring about that change and produce
a pipeline of promising talent
like tracy franklin as a woman who has
loved and appreciated whiskey for so
long and never seen her story
in the product to be able to create that
for other people is
beyond my imagination franklin is an
actress
turned bartender turned whiskey brand
ambassador
and now she's studying to one day
following green's footsteps as a master
distiller
it is my greatest dream are you getting
more clem
yes so the reason that this is so
emotional is because this is bigger than
me
this is about the ancestors this is
about people who lost that legacy the
stories that are forgotten
these are actually my three favorite
songs my dad ever
created for weaver that passion for
preserving forgotten stories hits close
to home
what did your father mean to motown
frank wilson was one of the original hit
makers for motown
weaver's father frank wilson wrote and
produced motown hits
for artists like stevie wonder smokey
robinson and the supremes
in 1965 he recorded his own song
[Music]
do i love you indeed i do became a cult
classic in the uk
but has never hit american airwaves with
wilson's voice
until now
[Music]
and then all of a sudden in the uk this
story breaks
that the most expensive motown record
ever
is sold and when it came time to do
our next commercial my dad's song just
started playing
in my head as another of her dad's hits
goes
weaver just keeps on trucking and in
this time of racial discord
she hopes that americans remember the
real lesson of nearest and
jack's unlikely friendship so it's
almost like jackin
and narrison are in heaven and going
let's go let's get out there and make
sure that
that they know it is possible for us to
love one another for us to treat each
other as
equal they did it and i think it's time
for us to do it again
well the uncle nearest distillery has
been closed to tourists since march
because of the pandemic but they are
still making whiskey and sales are
up jack daniels whiskey says the
advancement initiative honors quote an
extraordinary friendship
and helps him to become more intentional
about increasing diversity and
inclusion and uplifting our fellow human
beings and communities and what's so
funny is
you know fawn says you know the three
men i love or actually
four are on this her father
jack her husband is the voice and of
course uncle nearest
all in the same commercial the the
intentionality is really key there
because it didn't happen by accident
that all the black distillers
disappeared from the industry and
they're not going to come back by
accident either
good point you have to work for
diversity yes you do well